إذن ، ما مدى القلق الذي يجب أن نشعر به
ليس فقط بشأن ظهور
هذا البديل ولكن ربما الآخرين لأن
ما يقوله الناس لا بأس به الآن إنه
متغير دلتا ولكن ماذا عن
البديل التالي هل
سنبقى عالقين إلى الأبد في هذه
الدورة من الاضطرار إلى اللحاق بالركب
بالنسبة إلى المتغيرات الجديدة من فيروس كوفيد ، تتواجد
كبير مراسلينا الطبيين إليزابيث
كوهين هنا
أولاً مع أول واحد تم تحديده في
الهند ،
ما هو القلق
هناك هو أن هالة يبدو أنها قابلة
للانتقال
تمامًا وقد تجعل الناس مرضى أو
تجعلهم أكثر  من المحتمل أن ينتهي بهم الأمر في
المستشفى على الرغم من أنهم غير متأكدين من
ذلك ومع ذلك ما زالوا يبحثون في الأمر
ويبدو أنه يمثل تحديًا قليلاً
للقاح ، بمعنى آخر
، لا يعمل اللقاح جيدًا ضد
هذا  متغير
مثل المتغيرات الأخرى ولكن الاختلاف
صغير جدًا ، فلنلقِ نظرة على
هذه الأرقام
لأنه من المهم جدًا ألا
يخاف الناس من هذا
الأمر ، لذا إذا ألقيت نظرة على  في لقاح
pfizer ،
يكون فعاليته حوالي 88 ضد
هذا البديل الذي تم العثور عليه لأول مرة في
الهند ،
وعادة ما يكون أكثر من 95 فعالية ، لذلك
يعد هذا اللقاح
أكثر
فعالية ضد هذا النوع الذي
تم العثور عليه لأول مرة في الهند.  أن تكون أقرب إلى
66 وهذا للأشخاص الذين تناولوا
كلتا الجرعتين ، وحيث
مر أسبوعان ، يكون هناك اختلاف بسيط
ولكن انظر إلى هذه الأرقام
88 60 ، فهذه
اللقاحات فعالة للغاية جدًا ،
خاصةً شركة Pfizer ،
وهكذا إذا  على سبيل المثال ، عندما
تقدمت شركات الأدوية إلى إدارة
الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
للحصول على إذن لطرحها في
السوق ، قالت إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) إننا نريد فقط 50
فعالة من هذا القبيل ستكون كافية
وهنا لديك 60 و 88 لذا
فإن القلق الذي كنت تقوله من قبل
حول هل سيستمر هذا وما
يثير القلق ليس كثيرًا
أنه سيستمر ويستمر على الرغم من أنه من الواضح أنه
لا أحد يريد
أن يكون هناك نوع
من المتغير  omes على طول حيث لا
يكون فايزر ليس فعالًا بنسبة 88 في المائة حيث
يأخذ حقًا ضربة
في الوقت الذي من المحتمل أن نكون فيه في
مأزق